>>SOWS.
AUTOPSROM LOS
ANLES COUNTY THE MEDICAL
AMVEFRIENDS ARINE ANUENT DROWNI.
L D OCTOBER.D HI
SAY  FETH WAGMEISTER IS
FOLLOWING ANGELES.
ELIZABETH, WMOS THE
L REPORTAV SAY?
AUTOP
MATTHEW PERRY DID FRACUTE OF KED
DG.
OUND F
OORITIES SAY THERE S  PLAY.
NOW FOR FIEPORT, WE ARE GEGCONFN
WHO FIRST FOUND HES LIVE IN ASSA
HOME FROM RUNNING ERRAND S IN TP
S BO AD 9-1-1.
THIS ASSISTANT REPORT
TO NOT WANT ONE ANY ILLNESSES
ORG USE OR DRINKING, BUT
REPORT THN
MATTHEW PERRY'S SYSTEM AWAS REPN
KETAMI INFN
TREAT DEPRESSD
ANXIETY.
>> INTERESTING.ELIZABETH, STAND.
I WANT TO BRING IN CHIEF
MEDICAL CORRESPONDENT DR.
SANJAY GUPTA.
TH I IS SOMETIMES USED TO
TREAT DEPRESSION AND AELIZABETHY
IF YOU REA'S DETAILED REPORT.
ABOUT 40 P.THEY
RECEIVED, HE WAS RECEIVING
INFUSION THERAPY OFF KETAMINE,
H CAN BE USED TO HELP TREAT
DEPRESSION ANDBUT  LAST INFUSIOS
ABOUT A WEEK AND A
EARLIERTO COFFEE SOME CONTEXT,E
-L JUSHO OH, OKAY.
HE COULD BRENGS LI GBE
RAPY, T IT'S NOT
LIKELY IT HAD ANYTHING TO DO
WEE TALKING ABOUT
HERE.
PUT THIS ON YOU. SAYING,
RT THEY HAVTH, LIST
OF CSEOF DEATH.
INGS THAT CONTRIBUTED TOH.
KETAMINE, ISHEY SAUTE THING.
OWNING?
MES IN A POLL.
TYPE OF OPIOID. DISE
T REALLY SOU,
AND HOW REPORE
TOOK KE,GAKE FROM THE
IN DID HAVE SOME
AND IT'S AN ANESTHETIC LIKE
DRUGKE.
FF E
TAMINE THAT WAS
YOU THE LEVE WE CA
NANOGRAMS.TYPIY  W AROUND 3200 O
GENERAL ANASTASIA IS AROUN1000 .
HAVING SAID THAT
AND AND TE WANT VERY
O  TO
E TO DIEXCEPT FOR
FACT HE SO IN A SWIMMING
SO KETAMINAND THE POLLLTHE THIN.
TALKED TO A FEW
KETAMINE ISN'T LY WHATMPLY, AT
LL, BUT
OR HIM TO DROWN.
LLY SAD, JAKE.'S HOW IT SOUNDS.
THAT W
HA
SELF PSCRIBING?K
MEDICINEE TO GETHI
AND DEPRESSION?
DRUGS. RECREATIONALLY.
YEAH, WELL.
USE OHING
DEPREIO
LIKE HWAS
TTAT THERENDN
DSTREAM.
BUCAN ALAKS AG.
POINT,Y KNTA IT.
HICH HKING
THEY D FIND TRNTAS WELL.
T'LYTHOSE THGSTRUE.
TING I A THEPY,
BUT ALSO ON HIS OWN.
MISUSING IT.
>>ADNING.
ETH, MATTHEW PERRY WAS A
HIS STRULES
WITH DRUGS.
ISAIDE DIED,D ATNG, HELD
OR HELPING
INDIVIDUALS WHO SO ADDICTION.
ABSOLUTELY.
TO MATTHEW'S LIFE.
AS YOU S
STRUGGLE WITH ADIO MEMORY THAT T
HE HABEUT A YEAINTO GREAT DETA.
REHAB 15 TIMES.
ONOFRS OHIS JOURNEY
D  SAI WHAT HE WANTED
TOEDUS
G OTHERS.
AND FAT, JUST EARLIER TH WEEK,
S FRIENDS COSTARTERVIEW.
HEALTHY.HE WAS TEXTINGMATTHEW PS
AND THATHAT SHE
WANTS EVERYO TO
REMEMBER